all right hey welcome everybody I'm Nick
I've wanted to give this talk for really
long time this is a session about
pausing little languages in c-sharp so
you might call them to me specific
languages maybe but really we're talking
about any kind of little language that
you could embed into your own
applications and I really want by the
end of this talk for you to feel like
you not only could but that you might
actually consider giving this sort of
thing a try and real-world projects so
unfortunately if you read too quickly
and you got pausing c-sharp and you're
expecting a Roseland talk the door is
still open but I can't really think of
anything that I've that any programming
technique that I've learned that has had
a bigger impact on the kind of software
that I could consider writing than this
so even if you were expecting Rosslyn
you still probably might get something
out of this this hour so let's get stuck
in let's pay a clicker so Eric Maya who
I think you'd probably recognize for his
work in c-sharp on the link language
features particularly he once quipped
that dependency injection is for
programmers who don't know maths he's
got a good sense of humor I think but so
sometime back in 2008-2009 I was sitting
at my desk
hey my boss is really interested in this
dependency injection stuff we're just
down in the cafe could you come down and
maybe answer a few questions for us I
show up at cafe Eric Meyer okay so the
first time I publicly admitted this but
I feel some kind of responsibility is
that I might have failed to really get
the beauty and joy of composition using
IRC and dependency injection across him
but at the same time it came down to I
came to write this talk and there's
those words again and I thought yeah
well
I've got an hour to deliver the talk and
I won't get all the content into an hour
surely so we'll save ten minutes for the
questions at the end and then I need at
least 30 slides so how long have I got
to present each slide and if we all tab
across thought well I don't learn math
obviously but I know a few things about
computers so could I come up with a
scheme to get a computer to solve this
problem for me so here you go at
something like one hour - 10 minutes for
questions
oh hang on oh and we need some parens
because I know nothing else about that
why the hell are - 10 minutes and how
many 30 slides ok so we've got 1 minute
and 40 seconds for each slide I can just
about squeeze it into that if we've got
10 minutes for questions at the end and
I'll probably need 30 seconds for every
question ten minutes divided by 30
seconds per question okay I probably
could have worked that out in my head
still and lots of domains it's really
nice to be able to express a problem in
a natural way and as programmers we
really intuitively know that languages
have the optimal vehicle for this just
switch back across sorry you it's a
little bit like if you remember when you
first encounter the database the the way
that you queried it was probably with
something like a visual query designer
where you dragged on tables and join
them up and and now that's a that's a
good experience if you have no if you
have no knowledge of databases and you
need to get data out but if you spend
all day every day dealing with an
application the way that the people who
use the software that all of us write do
then you know that often like being able
to express a query in sequel is a must
there's no way you could imagine being a
programmer and working with a query
design
in there and it's very much the same for
lots of lots of our users as well but
historically at least with the teams
I've worked with we're really really
hesitant to embark on adding languages
into up into our projects I'm not sure
if it's because we're afraid that
there's some specific knowledge that
means the next program are down the line
won't be able to maintain it I kind of
suspect that when we first encounter
languages it's in an academic setting
and there's a huge and really
interesting field to explore there and
all the really sophisticated techniques
that you might use if you're if you're
implementing something like a
programming language day to day it how
easy it is to use very simple techniques
to approach these problems in languages
like C sharp doing things like writing
business apps so once I discovered what
I was what what I want to show to you
today it was like having four loops in
the tool box or learning object-oriented
programming I mean there was just a
whole host of ways of approaching
software and ways of tackling problems
that all of a sudden became open to me
like when I started working on octopus
deploy right back with poster ville
there was a feature where you could
substitute variables into your
configuration files but you can generate
configuration files or conditionally
construct those and so a little language
was born in there for conditionally for
flow control and and looping that let
you do a lot more I'm sure some of you
probably have used those sorts of
techniques today and I can't imagine
octopus without it myself
I worked with a hospital who had a an
admission system for expecting expectant
mothers coming in to give birth and
there was this legislated list of
questions that had to be asked in a
particular way and it would they the
questions would change every month sorry
every year that they had to answer and
deliver back to the health department
unfortunately because this was
implemented as a large web performance
application it took something like 18
months to go and grind through that list
of quest
turned into an app that you could
actually enter data into so there's
obviously a problem there and once we
came back to taking the questions as
they were delivered and using a small
language to conditionally show or hide
those questions based on previous
answers we took that whole process down
from 18 months to a matter of hours
unfortunately we build it in a
Silverlight and and literally one month
after we finished the project the
hospital I believe standard that has
some iPads and that was the end of that
so he went some you lose some
I also when I when I hit the problem of
getting better diagnostics out of dotnet
apps spotted a chance for using the
languages in logging which might have
encountered in stereo log and Sarah logs
got a filtering filtering language built
into it too which is something that like
that's also indispensable in this kind
of software but these are things that I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have imagined
attempting to write hadn't had I'm not I
kind of ripped the bandage often and
learned how to deal with tech pausing
text so if we go back and have a look at
the little duration calculated that we
ran earlier most of you can probably see
the essence of the the problem just
straight off the straight off the bat
like that when we want to evaluate
something like one hour - 10 minutes
divided by 30 we kind of intuitively
know that that the shade of the problem
is a tree and irrespective of the
programming language it's pretty normal
to represent these sorts of structures
in trees for example we might have
abstract hierarchy where there's
expression duration value numeric value
and some kind of binary expression
though that can have a left and a right
expression and operator most of us are
fairly comfortable with working with
trees because we do that every day so
why is it that oh and of course here's
is I think just case in point that the
code to evaluate this particular
language once you have kind of kind of
gotten your problem into the shape of a
tree is very short II you could sweat
away over over switch statements or and
recursion in the afternoon and and be
able to compute a result so everyone's
fairly comfortable I guess with
recursion with yeah everyone will be
quite happy with a tree and writing a
procedure to go through and evaluate
this but be comfortable with writing a
positive to get to the tree this was
this was my pretty common as well so
we've got the input language and it's a
string of characters and we want to
somehow just bunch those up in just the
right way that once we've processed
those and walked through them we'll have
a tree that we can then go and use for a
regular programming to to evaluate the
nice thing is that this is just
programming but unfortunately the the
techniques are kind of distinctive to
this space so we've all seen our regular
expressions can can be used to chop up a
string into into components that are all
linear but if you want to produce a tree
from that output you have to reuse a
parser there's no recursion in regular
expressions and there's no or there's no
stack I guess and trying to use one
where you need the other is obviously
world of pain so what is a passer
so deep no a parser is just a function
that takes a string as input essentially
and gives you a value as an output
that's kind of everything and nothing
about the problem right
to make useful parsers that can manage
sophisticated languages that we have to
be a little bit more prescriptive and
although our positive functions are
going to have very much that shape of
taking it and take your string as an
input produce the result is an output I
want to introduce you to two little
structs that will appear through the
code that we're going to write input
wraps the source string and it gives you
a position into that string so where
you're up to as far as having consumed
the the characters to produce that value
and a result tells you whether you
whether you successfully passed a value
or not and in both cases either what was
the remainder after passing the value or
where did you hit the error and there's
not really a way to kind of just
continue these are both immutable so you
don't kind of go around and push the
position of an input along so together
you get a new input you have to consume
a character from an existing input and
then using next char and that will give
you a value and the remainder so how's
this going to work this is a very it's a
very simple parsing problem it's not the
most simple but let's take natural
numbers for example the algorithm for
parsing a natural number if you think
about working through this one character
at a time is that we see at one if we're
sparse 123 and then we move on and is
the next character also a number and if
it is we'll multiply that first one that
we saw by 10 to shift it up a place and
then tack on the next thing that we saw
which is that too as we keep working
through this through that string at each
time we find another character we'll
multiply whatever we've got it got by 10
and then take that last one I'm so mad I
can get that by now it's a little bit
noisy once you include input and result
into into the equation but here's here's
a reasonably defensible part of the
parser for working through an input and
parsing off the natural number and
giving
the remainder whatever whatever input
has not yet been parsed and it's not
code that I like it's fairly ugly but
it's code that anyone given some some
time to think about the problem could
obviously put together so parses being
functions we can write functions to do
all kinds of parsing tasks and we don't
necessarily have to write an a function
if we just want to parse the letter A or
a B function to pass the letter B the
char function here is a parameterised
parser where you can tell it which part
which character you want to match so it
might be in a b c and then the result of
that that char function will be a the
character if that was the first thing
that was seen the input or it might be
an empty result if that if that
character didn't appear so if you've got
a character positive for parsing natural
numbers which there wasn't any magic in
and once or any magic or char that char
unicode info docket digit value is
probably magic I don't know how that
works there's got to be something
shifting involved in that but if you can
pass natural numbers and you can parse
characters you can imagine writing
another positive for fractional parts
which is very much like natural except
that instead of multiplying by 10 each
time we move out of place
every time we move off into those
fractional digits which is that way for
you then we would divide the the next
number by 10 to add it on so given three
fairly simple fairly simple parses we
can then go and write another function
and it's also got that same signature
where we're taking an input and provided
producing a result and this one's going
to parse decimal numbers in this case we
apply the natural positive the whole
part if we failed then we bail out if we
can then pass a dot we move on we don't
really do anything with that value
and then we apply the fraction Pazza and
if the fraction part has a value then
we're able to add the whole in
fractional parts and there we go we have
a double what do you think of this code
I hate it I can't imagine I can't
imagine trying to maintain any kind of a
giant code base that's written in that
style that's probably why you wouldn't
imagine being able to scale from some
sort of simple little parser that looks
at numbers up to being able to really
pass a whole programming language with
these techniques but let's tear it all
down reset and start again
so because pauses are functions that
there are some tools in c-sharp for
dealing with functions that we can apply
to make working with pauses a lot easier
and much more pleasant the term might
kind of be higher-order functions but we
don't want to get too technical right
not getting into maths or anything like
that either
this Pazza so to declare a parser we
first needed a delegate type to work
with passes as functions we need a
delegate type the the positive t
delegate is just capturing that
signature where we've got an input and
we're returning a result with value once
we have that delegate type though we can
start to write other functions that will
process parses into new passes and many
is a really really a really neat little
example here where we have a positive
for an item and you can imagine that
being something that turns Smiley's into
the unicode equivalence and then we have
this function many and if we call many
with the smiley parser passed in we get
a new positive that can give us lists of
spy Smiley's that's really powerful
concept but to fit that model of course
we then have to go back and revise
things like char and char now tin in
this version of the code is a function
that doesn't actually do the parsing but
will take the input and we're sorry that
would that would take the character and
then close over that and give us a new
positive that that will match that
character
so back to the problem of parsing
decimal numbers the repeated code that
we saw in there was that apply one
parser check whether the result had a
value if it didn't return an empty value
with a particular remainder and if it
did move on to the next part so given
that we can work on parses this way this
this function then is a sequencing
operator that will take the deposit
which is the first thing that we're
going to try to match and then return
the new parser that are in the second
part we're going to try to match and
then return new positive that's going to
apply the first and then apply the
second and inside the body of that
little lamda there you can see the same
pattern that repeated three times in
parsing decimal the return function is a
helper that will see used in the next
little slide and it just is a simple
simple puzzle that always returns a
value regardless of the input and
doesn't consume anything but with these
two ingredients we can take a much
better swing at building a maintainable
parser out of those component passes
that we've already constructed so you
can see here the nice thing about this
is it as well that it reads like English
or reads like the grammar that describes
the language so to pass a double we pass
an opossum natural type Oh didn't spot
that then we we take that whole part
that was passed and we construct a char
parser and if that matches then we take
the dot and ignore it and then we apply
the fractional part and then if those
have all succeeded we return the whole
number plus the fraction so this
technique is really is really
interesting not just because it's
succinct but also because it's kind of
fractal you can take a simple parser and
build a more complex parser and with
just these few building blocks you can
you can build passes for really
arbitrarily complex languages that all
have the same kind of structure at each
level and this techniques been known for
quite a long time as I think at least
not since the 60s but
quite another people have worked on it
and two computer science researchers
cemented its popularity I think with an
article in 1996 about it and one of
those of course happens to be Eric Amaya
and so given that dr. Meyers had
something to do with this it's probably
no surprise at all that the c-sharp
language has some really good facilities
for doing this kind of functional
programming and this kind of combination
of pausing big things from small things
so with the c-sharp query comprehensions
we can create a function called select
many which fits into that from
instructure and it behaves very much
like then and so now we not only have a
composable way of building parsers but
we have a little domain-specific
language that lets us express things
like from well we take the whole but we
take the the dot and then we take the
fraction and all of the features of link
like let and we're going there to give
us a really a really succinct and
powerful language for writing passes so
I think that's really awesome then of
course and return and not the only games
in town once you've got this capability
there are all sorts of things that you
can cook up to tackle different kinds of
syntactic structures like if you are
positing a list then you can write a
Combinator called many and it will take
an item parser or many delimited by will
take those items and look for another
parser in between them like the comma
that you'd find between items in a java
script list for example so the even
better news is that you don't have to go
and write all of this yourself if you
were really itching though to get back
in back back to the hotel room and crack
open an ID and start writing parsers
that's totally cool and I don't wanted
to tell you but there are some libraries
already available in c-sharp and done
that for doing this the one that we're
going to look at through some some
further examples is called super power
is this is the second attempt that I've
trying to write a parser combinator
library for c-sharp and this one comes
with of course a set of Combinator's
like then and and many and or and it
also comes with a very large library of
pre-built pauses like the numeric pauses
and pauses for decimal syntax and those
kinds of things so it can take a lot of
that nitty-gritty out of trying to build
a parser for a new language it's still
good to know though how all of those
little individual unit passes are
working because the nice thing about
working with positive combinators is
they still are just code and they run
like programs and if you can write code
you you can debug code you can you can
try writing a positive for a particular
kind of language and then you can you
can debug your way through that which is
which is a big difference from if you're
trying to express something in an e BN f
grammar and use the language workbench
and yeah of course there's some there's
a whole lot more to it to that we're
gonna have a look at so the first part
will look at this built of superpower is
this one called magnitude if you recall
we have a little domain-specific
language for computing durations and the
unique thing I think about that language
is just the duration syntax I say unique
it appears in a few places but it's not
something you typically find in in
day-to-day programming languages and
this parser is called magnitude because
it's what we're going to use to pass
that little trailing piece of tech stuff
and the number to decide how big that
duration is it's not called duration
because we've already a library passive
for passing numbers okay so when we want
to pass ten minutes we just need to find
the minutes bit and then we'll multiply
that by ten to get ten minutes written
here it's quite verbose and being a
being a program it could be refactored
I haven't done that just because I think
the structure is nice and clear
and you if you read your way through it
you can see that we'll try to match a
character D and if that's if that
matches the value is one day or we'll
try to match the character H and that'll
be it with the value of an hour
things get a little bit interesting
around M&Ms now if we were to put
minutes ahead just following that
sequence that we have been working
through and we encountered an M in the
input then that empowers would succeed
and we never looked to see whether
there's a trailing s to decide whether
it's minutes or milliseconds this is
kind of one of the consequences of
writing a part of like a dumb program
but it's also one of the benefits
because the way that you resolve these
sorts of ambiguities is really
straightforward if you're used to
sequencing programs it's like well of
course we'll just try the MS bit first
before we try and match the M in that
way if we could chomp up that whole MS
then we don't don't need to try the M
and if we fail we'll just backtrack and
the M power will kick in try stuck in
the middle there I should say character
equal to D or character equal to H is
exactly the char parser that we saw a
few minutes ago it's just that it's
organized alongside a whole lot of other
kinds of char passes like letter and
digit and those sorts of things under
that character class if we parse our way
through something with the superpower
and we fail partway through the input
then that will generally completely fail
the whole parsing the whole parsing a
job because reporting errors really
really relies on giving back information
that's really specific so if we if we
parse our way through some input and we
fail that's it or doesn't actually try
to pick up another another parser and
try the next one in the sequence and so
the try Combinator is in there that
causes this one to backtrack because we
do want to continue if we partially mash
EMS I didn't I didn't say this was all
going to be super super super easy
only that it's coded and that it's
understandable from that perspective of
working through an algorithm rather than
trying to understand a grammar once we
have magnitude we can start to pass
durations and in this instance we used
the decimal double parser
and it matches the numeric part and the
name is awful but the name comes about
because the library of parsers were
using has pauses that simply match a
span of text with names like decimal and
then they have there's a vet there's a
lot of variants for some of them for
efficiently turning that span of text
into a particulate on that type there is
decimal
there's decimal double there's also a
decimal decimal token just tells us that
it's okay to surround that with white
space so it's another puzzle that goes
and tries to chomp through as much white
spaces it finds before applying the
positive that it wraps and then we see
them as we did in that in the earlier
one where we try and apply magnitude and
if we succeed on both then we can pop
back out a duration a duration that that
captures that time span that that the
expression or the token has isn't
encoded
so one of the strong benefits of this
parsers being code and passes being the
same at all levels is that you don't
just test the overall grammar for the
whole programming language or justment
domain-specific language that you're
building here we've got a test that's
just for gr8 parsing durations and we
can use a little help a function called
test pass a sorry try parcel which we'll
just go and apply that part we've passed
through she's the one we're testing give
it some input and then we can assert
different things about what we've got
out of that and that works whether we're
talking about pausing a duration pausing
some kind of binary operation or pausing
the entire expression and these are
these are also highly amenable to
data-driven testing where we take a
whole list of possible inputs and we
loop through and and put them through a
function like this and test them against
their list of possible outputs so to
counter anyone who tells you that you
shouldn't write parses in your biz apps
or whatever it is that you're that
you're doing for real parses are so much
more regular and and so much more
testable and modular than anything like
a web form that they're really they're
really much more controllable when you
when you're doing things like testing
and changing them I mean I can imagine
there's some really colossal web forms
out there that that no one would think
twice about writing but which is
certainly not anywhere near as testable
as a parser I can also imagine somebody
right now sitting behind their cubicle
monitor in some colossal MBC form like
and Entering durations and checking them
with checkboxes and grouping them up and
applying operators like yeah the
alternative of writing things without a
parser is often a lot messier than if
you're if you're going to use these
techniques so given that we can pass
durations and passing operators is
pretty simple
here I have factored things a bit the OP
function takes the symbol and then the
parser that represents but the sorry
takes the symbol and then the enum
member that represents the operator and
so we have plus
gives this operator ad and um- gives us
subtract and so on and so again it's
just programming so we can get those
four for the price of kind of one and a
half we won't do too many more slides of
just kind of like piles of piles of
pausing code but this one is the meat of
the duration language that we've been
looking at and we probably need to spend
a little bit of time looking closely at
it because this is I think the the one
that captures the difference between the
really linear parsing that we've been
doing and being able to kind of
recursively construct those those
expressions that are that we're going to
represent as trees so literal is pretty
simple it's the the lowest level kind of
node in the language so literal is
either a duration or a number and we see
because durations start with numbers we
have to backtrack potentially using try
so that we don't fail having seen just
the numeric part factor as has an
interesting name and the names may be a
little off-putting but factor is the the
part of this language where it might be
what you would find on the left left or
right hand side of a multiplication or a
division because we're dealing with
operator precedence the things that kind
of bound more tightly wrapped up towards
the top of these little parses and the
things that are bound more loose they're
down the bottom so a factor we have a
left paren and then we recursively pass
an expression and then a right paren and
so this is how that how you apply the
language to sorry this is how you
applied the positive to something like
at 100 - 10 minutes in brackets so that
so that that's grouped up and can be
multiplied by another value and if
otherwise the the literal is the kind of
tightest unit and if we go up a little
bit further on we've got two
which is something that you might add to
something else and it uses a helper
function called chain because pausing
left associative Graham expression
grammars like this one is a really
common task and so there's lots of
little library helpers to make that
easier and chain will just take take
deposit for the value and then whatever
the the auto sorry it will take the
operator and the operands and you and
use that to construct some kind of
binary expression node term and
expression are really very similar in
that one is applying more flower divide
Dylan applying add or subtract this
could be a little bit it could be a
little bit horrific still to look at and
I think this is one of the other points
that's important to realize when you set
out to build a positive or a language
that you've concocted for your own
purposes when you when you set out to
write a language to solve a problem it's
very rare that the language is the
interesting thing it's usually the
problem that's the interesting thing the
the model of your domain is where
everything that's unique to your
language is going to be so I can write 1
plus 1 in JavaScript or sequel or sequel
query or probably in XSLT if I encode it
right and that looks the same in all of
those since in taxes but the the
semantics of I've actually executing
that is very different so if you put
your x-ray goggles on you can see that
there's a whole lot of commonality
between most of the languages that we
that we as programmers were designed to
solve problems we have you might have
expressions there's there's data types
like strings and lists and numbers and
no one no one goes out to invent their
own decimal syntax or and if you've got
to encode strings then you probably
adopt something like JavaScript strings
or sequel strings and so because of this
there are there are only really a few
sort of skeletons for most of the kinds
of languages that you might write and I
can't sit and write
the correct code for a parser like that
expression one we were just looking out
on the first pop off the top of my head
however I don't need to because I open
up any example expression positive
written with super power or otherwise
and I that structure is kind of there
and documented and somebody else has
solved that problem before so you don't
think that yet I don't think you really
have to go back and really understand
every every single approach to every
parsing problem to be able to be
effective with this stuff take a little
bit of the pain sometimes and things
like constructing an expression tree and
then and then adding in those elements
like different kinds of values and
different kinds of operations is where
your language will become interesting so
before we can run the deposit that we
have written for expressions it's
important to check that the part of the
string that we're trying to parse is
actually the complete input so you can
see there's one one little helper
they're called source which takes the
expression uses a Combinator called at
end just to assert that the result of
that pass has consumed everything and
then try pars is just a little wrapper
that that goes and constructs the source
object and cause the parser and returns
a result out but so that all adds up to
give us what we've been looking at a few
minutes ago so if we have a look at how
it behaves you see it does work I think
oh yes I should probably um hey I can't
we probably need some brackets there for
what that would make any sense so that
that red arrow there is one that you get
when the expression syntactically makes
sense but that's in the evaluator as
said well you've got a a time value when
you're trying to a subtraction number
but there are other kinds of mistakes
that we can make when we're when we're
working with the languages and most of
the time because this is built with a
framework that has a whole lot of code
for dealing with producing good error
messages from from broken parses you'll
get a message that makes some sense yeah
there might not be enough input there
might be something like I channeled my
German heritage 45 tug there we go an
unexpected T or something that just
doesn't make any sense at all now but
this is where the difference between
different approaches to parsing start to
really make it really make themselves
felt because an error message like
unexpected one when you're looking at an
input like 10 10 makes sense to a
developer if that was in the exception
message if that was an exception message
and I knew that I was pausing some kind
of expression that I'd be perfectly fine
with going and tracking that down
however little languages will crop up
that that make it easier to write
programs but they're mostly for the
benefit of users so if we were going
into to actually ship something like
this in in a replacement for a giant a
giant web form oh hang on I can't f5
that I might want it to look a little
bit a little bit more like this okay so
here we have our old inputs a 10 plus 45
okay so this is this is telling I've got
an invalid duration I've got an
unexpected T if I have ten ten again an
error that's an unexpected number ten so
these are these are starting to approach
the kinds of error messages that you
could show to a to a human user and
maybe this could be another reason for
the trepidation that people feel when
they're going to add a parser into a
real-world project because producing
good error messages for users that make
sense and don't result in you know
emails and support calls is a little bit
trickier but I think it's important to
understand where that lines drawn so
that if you are in one of the one of the
boats or the other whether you're
writing a parser that's going to be used
by developers probably yourself or your
in team versus if you're going to have
third party users you you're probably
better off setting setting off down the
right path from the very beginning and
so to produce better error messages like
these ones we need to go just a little
bit further so the technique that that
produces messages like unexpected
duration expected operator it is made
much easier by an approach called token
driven passing and I think that the
techniques were sorry I skipped ahead
but if you take a cat the character
stream we've been passing like a simple
little operator like that we're looking
at everything a character at a time and
that's very useful for our understanding
of that task because the person makes a
lot of it makes a simple algorithm
working through the cat those characters
and everything sort of at the same the
same at every level but to a user
there's a lot of higher order structure
in their users are typically going to be
thinking of those as as whole tokens
like 10m is a is a duration I'm not
really looking at a 1 a 0 and M when I'm
a user and so the job of a tokenizer
which is a kind of a just offense a
glorified preprocessor for for input
like this is to go through in group
those tokens and discard all of that
trivia that you don't need in order to
successfully pass the thing by doing
that we can attach a whole lot of
information to those in the process it's
not the same it's not the same as just
doing some parsing first because
tokenization is really is still a bit
much more like what you would do with
string dots little regular expressions
is it's a simple process that's not
particularly intelligent it doesn't tell
you what the role of one of those
structures is it will just tell you what
they are so left paren is a left paren
the divide operator might be a divided
operator or it could be the start of a
comment so it's just a slash and when we
tagged those tokens that were found in
the token string with their kind we just
come along and chomp them up exactly the
same way as that week as we did the
other the other characters in our first
first version so to convert the paths
that we've already got to a token parser
we have to start with a declaration of
what kinds of tokens are in there if you
open up the Roslyn sauce you find
something pretty similar to for all of
the is quite mind-boggling looking at
all the tokens that are used to pass
c-sharp but in this case we've got
expression token I tried to keep the
names really short so they fit on slides
this is using just simple members of a
number and duration when you see those
in a message that's just the name of the
token example the example there just
makes it possible to say expected l /
expected l / n rather than the word l /
n now taking the input and processing it
into a list of tokens is a job for a
tokenizer which you can write by hand if
you really want a fast
industrial-strength kind of tokenizer or
if you're using superpower that we look
at we're looking at you can use a
shortcut method called tokenizer builder
and that is is really just a list of
rules that you will apply one by one
through the input and as soon as one of
those matches then produce a particular
kind of token and add that to the stream
that were going to parse later on it
really reads top to bottom
and when you see match character equal
to plus that's the same kind of
character positive that we were just
looking at in the simple text parts or
example again we've got a little bit of
a little bit of ordering and ambiguity
to deal with and at the end we have a
span dot whitespace to discard all of
the stuff that we want to ignore you'll
see duration is tucked in there and that
that duration is not from the library of
pauses that super power provides it's
just the text parser that we wrote that
turns durations in time spans it doesn't
matter what kind of output the other
parts of producers to use it in a
tokenizer like this so you can build
tokenize this really quickly some
subtleties there's a little example in
the bottom left corner corner depending
on how you want to structure your
language you might not be comfortable
with 4/4 5d6
being a duration 45 days and then the
number 6 in that instance if we have a
duration or a number we might want to
require that some other tokens appear
around them so they're delimited and
that's what that extra flag that's
getting passed through to those rules is
if we go through the passes that we
already have declared and see how they
get transformed by this process the
structure stays very much the same and
that's this is something that it took a
long time for me really to really
realize the technique even though you're
working on tokens instead of characters
it's just the same you work through and
you want to match some particular thing
it's not a another character a character
equal to something here we go and match
that a token of the kind expression
token dot number and then we take that
value apply some kind of text parser to
it to generate some strongly type thing
and then we turn that into the node
that's going to go into expression tree
but the transformation is pretty
mechanical and you can really start out
with the text parser and move to a token
parser or I'd imagine you'd want to go
the other way but factor is another
example that just shows how the
structure is very much the same we have
we're passing a left paren first instead
of that being the character is the token
and
then we go back and recurse over the
expression or we end up trying to pass
the literal rule if we don't see a left
paren and the parser the Combinator
names are all very similar as well for
working with tokens are working with
characters in super power so it's a
little bit of a Swiss Army knife luck
library in that it has facilities that
kind of match for both of these things I
ended up writing it mostly because I was
doing a lot of character based parsing
but getting frustrated and not being
able to produce error messages that
people can understand and then having to
answer questions about why something was
broken okay so a little bit of an
example now though of one of the other
benefits of of having a tokenizer
instead of just writing the parser
straight out as a text parser now if we
want to put some sort of commenting
capability into our into our
particularly throat today sorry into
this language so so everyone be able say
one plus I have no idea three you know
then we can just go and apply another
add another ignore rule to this list in
the tokenizer
and we can knock that out but those
comments out before it even gets down to
the pausing stage and we don't need to
go through and examine every rule in
that parser we're going to write where
we're dealing with this with the
structure of the grammar and worry about
say I want to pause the duration or I
might have to pass the start of a
comment so ordering matters because
comments and and division begin with the
same character and this is a comment C
style
and if we add that one little rule then
we can say one class and then comment
something in there and we get four so
token parsing despite having a little
bit more overhead has a lot has a lot of
flexibility that gives that gives you a
chance to I'm really you can't you've
got a whole exit extra hole extra stage
in that process that you can use to deal
with these kinds of annoying source
processing tasks that otherwise make the
pies are a lot harder to right now we
might have we might have time to have a
look at a little bit more of an example
another thing that how are we going yes
we have ten minutes to go just short job
merits all right um I'm also I'm also
doing in another session upstairs on
level four after this which is an AMA so
if we ran out of but run out of time
I'll be you hanging around up somewhere
up there as well too
later in the afternoon if you really
want to go and like crackly crack this
solution open and start tinkering with
puzzles or if you've got other questions
that we don't get time to talk about but
given that we had a two we've got a
two-minute budget let's imagine that we
want to start to say what was the time
what's the time seven days ago
the way I would tackle that is we might
say now - seven days and just to prove
that there's no now in there I want to
show you what it takes to extend this
this grammar to just take do that one
more interesting thing and we'll do it
by adding an hour token and we could
call an hour keyword to choosing tokens
to be more specific rather than rather
than generic makes it easier to write a
really precise parser so we have so we
add our token there and the tokenizer
will have to produce those tokens when
it sees one in the input stream so we
look at the tokenizer and if we if we
see
if we see that span then we will yield
expression to again dot no yeah and
actually get us to now - seven days we
we got an unexpected now on now no we
won't we won't worry too much about how
to make that message clearer we expected
the duration a number so the problem
there is that there's nowhere in our
parser it has a rule that will match
that will match now and so we might have
to say a duration or number or now and
now it's going to be like these puzzles
that we've got for duration and for
number and but it's going to match a
token equal to now no expression token
now and it's going to have the value you
know expression no let's go up now value
typing his own okay
and they're always gonna he's gonna have
the same value because now will always
be something that we evaluate and rather
we don't have to have different kinds of
nails so we can just drop a Google Doc
ctrl C we can drop a node into the
expression tree it doesn't really matter
what it does oh no I don't do that no
okay
now I can move it and now if we run the
program hopefully that will work no
there's no covariance unfortunately we
have to cast it to an expression for
reasons of struct and and other things
being involved that c-sharp won't let us
use their hands for so now a - seven
days okay so now we're getting somewhere
so so once we evaluate once we evaluate
that expression we're going to need
another elements in our switch statement
here yeah and that's going to be we're
going to match a nail value and the
result is going to be a new date time
result and that can just be dead time
but now I would always use UTC did you
see by the way okay yep
and all right we have to implement to
string just so we can show this in the
output or just to say okay
we're getting close
you me that's my test let's just turn
these tests yeah okay now we've worked
our way through so we can accept now -
seven days and we have value seven days
can't be subtracted from right now okay
we go the chat would take the challenge
in the evaluator we're going to dispatch
a subtract so if the left is a duration
result no if the left is a it's going to
be a date time result DT and right is
duration and result will say de then we
can take so if we have a if I have a
date time and we subtract a duration we
have another date time and that's going
to be the date time value look let's say
- the okay and that's going to be de we
better actually add something to that
okay property value I shouldn't have
called it now should i okay
let's say value was now and then we can
just do Lu Chi string
hmm why do we not get that right I guess
we have to dispatch that let's see if we
get it let's see if we get a syntax
error we didn't so now - seven days I
hope you could follow all of that but
just on the fly I suppose right there's
not this is again you can just take an
existing take an existing grammar and
bunk thing is in and hack away until it
works and impress all of your colleagues
with fun little languages in your
programs so we talked a bit about text
parsers which means use to the start and
we really show you how text parsers are
just programs that chomp through strings
and return results and we've got
Combinator's to do all sorts of fancy
things and make real sophisticated
parses out of those and then we've got
token parsers which take a bit more
machinery and they're not so they're not
so quick to write or understand but what
I really think if you are going to show
this language to a to an end-user then
you should consider taking that approach
and there's tools out there to do that
without a whole lot more effort than if
you were working with just the plain
text so quick recap languages really do
Rock I would hate to be living in the
access query designer all day and you
would - pauses the pauses of programs
you can all write programs you can write
parsers and you probably should you
should at least consider where these
things could make the software that you
build better because the hopefully torn
away the the veil and there's no magic
in there that you're not capable of just
getting in there and hacking out with
the debugger and unit tests and all the
usual tools that you use to to write the
software that you're already shipping so
I hope that you will give it a shot
thanks very much for coming along I
think I did I did want to call out so
we're looking at superpower there's
another language in c-sharp called
that's written in c-sharp sorry another
library in c-sharp called Sbrocco
which is similar but only deals with
text parsers that was my first attempt
it's still quite widely used and it's
probably a also a useful place to find
lots of examples if you want to pass
different kinds of languages because
there's JSON parsers and XML parsers and
all sorts of thing is written for that
there's a part of some folks at Stack
Overflow called pigeon and pigeon is um
pigeon is a performance-oriented kind of
pose a positive Combinator library
versus superpower is much more oriented
towards those good and user error
messages so that might also be worth
looking at if you've got a lot of data
to process sadly it's not ten minutes
and so the joke is the Joker's gonna
fall on its face but we might have a few
minutes for some questions if anybody
has anything they'd like to ask Michael
are there limits to what can be passed
with Combinator's I'm really not the
person to answer that definitively I
think any sane language that you're
likely to want to pass yourself can be
it can be attacked this way so even
context sensitive languages where you've
got to carry some state down that tree
you might have to do a little bit of
acrobatics but yeah Combinator's can
definitely be used to attach to any
language that you'd see day-to-day
accommodators are really just a nicer
implementation of recursive descent
parsing which which has no one sort of
capabilities and it's it's used for most
of the programming languages that we
already work with so chances are pretty
good that whatever you're plugging into
your ID is getting passed with something
at least partially using these same
techniques any other ones that were
going to squeeze in okay thank you very
much for coming along it was lovely bye